Hello everybody My name is Markiplier
And welcome to Timore Inferno
Now this is uh...
This is a pleasant opening screen
To a game that I have played before
to a game that I have played before
Err at least I played the prior incarnation to this game
*BLEEP*
Whoa, hello, nice effects
*SQUEAAAK*
uh-HUH! At least they improved the door sounds
*INHALE*
But if its anything like the other Timore games I expect a lot of very,
VERY
High quality jumpscarage
Oh "look", what am I looking at?
Why am I looking?
What am I looking for!?
IDONKNOO
"They shouldn't have come here, you shouldn't have either"
Oh,
oooOOWOWOWO
(Mark shows off his karate moves)
*Deep inhale*
Hi...
*BLEEP*
Ugh, you are just uh, full of beans
*Beans spill out*
Oof, oof
Ok, scu, pardon me
Pardon me, OH
Hi,
Hello, OK,
Okay...
Wh-
Alright- (jumpscare) (screams)
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHH
(Was that qualiy jumpscarage, Mark?)
fffFFFFF-
*BLEEP*
Owa
I don't know if I should be lookn' at that guy,
I don't know if I should be looking at that guy.
Eugh
Is he lookin' at me?
(quietly) Nah, he's not lookin' at me.
OK
Okay-(car alarm sound)
(Quality jumpscarage)
(Mark does a karate)
*Laughs*
Wh-Wh-whahaht?
oowoow
AhwoowooWOOwoowoowoowoowoo
(DAB)
owowowowooowoow
*BLEEP*
Ohhhohohoho!
HE'S ALMOST ADORABLE! :D
Ohh look at you!
OH AIN'T YOU JUST A BAG OF DICKS!? :D
(Point of realization that there is something on the floor)
"Why is it looking at you?"
Why is WHAT looking at ME?
Errgh,
AHH
Fuck off
FUCK YOU!
What are you doing?! What are you doing?
Aww, is this just going to be my buddy now?
Well, I'm going to call you Oliver the Eye.
(But wait, thats the animators na-)
*Spoopy Noise*
[Oliver the Eye intensifies]
(distort, echoing, overlapping repeatly)
I'm gonna call you 'Oliver the Eye' ...
(And here we see a wild Cranbersher in its natural habitat)
Wait, what?
(Dark, offscreen) Let's go, Oliver.
(Darkiplier) We have an adventure to take care of.
*Stab*
(heartbeat rhythm begins to play)
Oliver!
OH NO!
I LOST OLIVER!
OOoohh Oliver
ooO no
oh no
oh hey
What are you?
Oliver?!
(Evil Oliver the Eye drew near!)
(Mark attempts to have a staring contest with an eyeball)
(Timeore?!)
Why are you back?
(Ah fak)
(weird monster sound)
*Spoopy noise intensifies*
Okay, ahAHHH
Darkiplier: I'M THE MONSTER HERE!
EUHAHAHAHHAHA
HAHAUHEHEUHEU
HAHAHAHHAHAHHAH
*Stab*
(Horror outro playing)